now going to look at five of the best
moves of one of my personal favorite
players of all time
Rashid and there's Medina otherwise
known as super mess fantastically
brilliant attacking player maybe the
best ever attacker of all time I'll let
you decide that remember to like and
subscribe to the channel now and I'm
going to show you a little bit of magic
from this five-time Russian champion in
this first example a legend of Soviet
chess polesky has just played the route
to h1 but the White King is hanging in
the center of the board and the next
move just embodies the kind of chess
that super there's played and I remember
seeing this next move when I was a kid
and it really was inspiring can you see
the move no retreat no surrender
remember pause draw nice examples if you
need to rook takes f4 blasting his way
through the board towards the White King
now in the game white took on h2 if
White had taken on f4 black can now play
can you see Bishop takes f4 check Knight
takes f4 and Knight takes c2 when white
has to give up his queen and still
beyond a major attack so after white
takes the Queen with route takes h2 we
now have a double check route to f3
check King to d4 black lines up the
Bishop Bishop to g7 a4 and nez just
keeps throwing the pieces at the White
King and the one thing here is even
though why is a queen up that King is
totally bare in the middle of the board
c5 check luckily White has on pasul but
black recaptures
with the renewed threats of c5 Bishop d3
the only move trying to make the king
and escape square night on e takes d
free with a big big check King to c4 and
now it's force mate d5 check pawn takes
pawn takes d5 King to b5
the pain doesn't stop for white yet rook
to b8 King - a five-night c6 check and
white resigned because after king to a6
there are two different ways
freedom ways that black can check me
I'll let you find the moves they're an
amazing example there but there's more
to come this next example just embodies
the idea of a positional Queen sacrifice
something that not many players are able
to do Black has just played Bishop to f6
attacking the Queen now most mortals
here would think oh my queen is attacked
I will retreat it but remember super Nez
has superpowers he comes at you like a
storm and here he plays Queen takes f6
and this is a simply astonishing idea
because the dark square control of and
squares in the center of the board the
point is if that Queen is taken White
will recapture with the bishop and then
the knight has this lovely square and
access into the black position similar
happens in the game Knight to e2 check
was played first and after Knight takes
pawn takes white simply moves his knight
back to C free and even though black is
serious material back with the knight
occupying the central square and the
dark squares being all under super nez's
control this proves to be a long-term
piece of simple magic I show you some
more Moo's rook e8 Knight d5 threatening
a big check rook comes to defend that
one and now the bishop increases its
power King g7 and white simply plays of
all his pieces rook d1 this work has a
very good future it's slow torture here
but it's torture that black can simply
not deal with and eventually white
breaks through towards the black King
still the game goes on for a little bit
but the whole idea of this original
sacrifice is something which sparkles
and creates a lovely piece of art on
64 squares I fought for our third
example we need to do Saeng a little bit
more simpler I say simpler is white to
play and win here and this one is still
very nice and crystal clear but it has a
lot of beauty involved look at the black
pieces what on earth are they doing over
there it's like they've run off the
board and they want to huddle in fear so
it's clearly time to strike Knight to f6
check and this blast open the black King
Black has to take this one I've why's a
white rook will dive into the seventh
rank but after pawn takes f6 white
simply recaptures wood the idea of
bringing the Queen to g7 simple and
crisp
tactic King h7 tries to the fan but
after a check and queen to g4 black
resigns in this position now I'll let
you guys discuss what may happen if
black aims of the fame but rookie a
black saw that white has a killer
against this can you see the killer I
hope you can take your time if you can't
relatively crisp and simple tactic here
super Meza has trapped his opponents
King on the King side can you find a way
to finish the game immediately white to
play Knight to f5 and the seemingly
impossible move threatens checkmate on
e7 the Queen and a lot of cases Queen
coming into d8 what can black do here
not much if black takes the knight in
anyway black loses the Queen which would
be enough to lose the game if black
plays Queen takes Queen Knight to e7 is
a simply lovely checkmate the game
continued with Queen to c5 chick but
after Bishop to e3 there's multiple
threats Queen to d8
and Bishop takes Queen Queen Cersei 7
was played the knight to h6 forced
resignation because rook takes f7 is
going to be checkmate next move
sometimes is a good idea to leave the
best until last
and I believe myself this is such an
example super Nez has the black pieces
he has many
arrows lining up against that poor
little guy over there but how does he
break through and again try to think of
the most forcing moves because that is
the way to do it in this position Queen
takes H to check King takes H to is
force but now the next move is the key
part of this tactic Knight to G free if
King to g1 root 2 H 1 is checkmate and
if King takes G free pawn to f4 ends the
game simply fantastic I hope you enjoyed
those examples comment below what was
your favorite example also do like this
video and subscribe to the channel
Aglio look at these videos
[Music]